welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 4
chapter 12 the siege in which maf
gideon's imperial forces
finally revealed their dark secret
agenda making the sequel trilogy
make sense nice
i'm gonna dive deep into the bombshell
star wars easter eggs drop this episode
along the way i'm gonna go frame by
frame to point out all the cool
hidden visual details the craft that
they put in this episode stuff that i
don't think anyone else catches because
no no they had friends in high school
spoiler warning and uh before i continue
you can get your hands on this custom
this is away shirt at new rockstars
merch store
newaccessmerch.com they're selling out
fast so jump on it look
like me scratch it that's not gonna move
any shirts
look better than me okay with the razor
crest still stitched together with mon
calamari
netting from trask mando uses baby
yoda's tiny body to try to repair the
ship from its inner bowels
i guess similar to the way they used his
disney cutie rival
baby groots to fit in a tight place in
guardians volume 2
really it reminds me of the way poe
dameron used bb-8 to plunge
inside the x-wing to try to patch it in
the last jedi which ended
the same shocking way for both christmas
gifts i might be reaching but i do find
it interesting that the child cannot
distinguish between the red and the blue
wires maybe he's color blind or
maybe just a baby but you know something
to be said for not being able to
distinguish between
red and blue oh i don't know lightsabers
a more balanced view of the force
careful of us casual speculation about
this kid gets grown adults screaming at
you about eggs on twitter
but when they sip broth mando just
slightly lifts his helmet
to eat
now he has mentioned having to eat this
way before but the fact that he does it
in front of the child right here
and baby yoda is looking right up in
there curiously is an
interesting reflection of how denjarin
is continuing to evolve
past the strict dogma of the watch that
bokeh tan pushed back on him on last
episode
this is the way this is the way back on
navarro
the forge formerly occupied by the
mandalorian armorer has been overtaken
by an aqualish gang this is the same
race as panda baba the jerk who picked a
fight with luke and obi-wan in the first
film
the spot where the mythosar skull statue
once hung is now empty leaving an
outline
marshall cara dune wrexham with gina
carano performing her own stunt role
though
this that has left that stunt mat
visible on the ground in the frame not
as bad as the dude in
jeans who shows up later or i guess a
[ __ ] coffee cup the decanter that
kara swipes at them is filled with blue
spatzka
the stuff you know she loves drinking
shame to waste it and she saves a lava
meerkat pretty sure we saw one of these
by the lava river on navarro in chapter
eight but before i continue we gotta
thank
desi shoes for sponsoring this video
whether you're hopping around the ice
planets of ilum hoth
jimmy or just wisconsin in the
wintertime you need shoes that will keep
your feet dry well lucky for us
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof
and weatherproof they're super
breathable with an antimicrobial insole
so your feet can smell good
and feel good like i imagine grief karga
must smell and feel
betsy's shoes are super stretchy they
fit like a sock and they only weigh 175
grams which is insanely light
considering they're stronger than
bescar steel they're made with the space
age dynamics material
so these are shoes you can wear every
day in all kinds of weather and they're
sustainably made
100 vegan and very easy to clean whether
you're hiking or running errands or
playing hopscotch on hoth besties will
keep your feet warm and dry and looking
great
i'm just doing some patio my
shoe got a little wet but you know what
did you wet my toes
still bone dry thanks to these besties
they also have an incredible early black
friday offer going on right now so go
grab yourself a pair for the rainy
season while they still have the sizes
and you can thank me later check them
out in the link below and if you missed
a black friday sale it's all good just
use my code new rockstars to get 25
off your besties shoes mando lands a
limping razor crest to greet kara and
magistrate grief karga
carl weathers directed this episode
actually i love how each flap of that
ship
wobbles independently the exhaust vents
blowing smoke chaotically when that ramp
doesn't budge all the way down star wars
production designers are always more
creative when the stuff they make has to
look worn and broken i love it and it's
still visible in mando's cargo bay is a
bounty frozen in carbonite thankfully
that did not get lost when the ship
cargo bay dangled open on the way to
trask now
this sneaky engineer is a mimbon the
race of one of the cloud writers in solo
star wars story there was also a member
nice pilot
in star wars squadrons now the town
looks great under grief and kara's
leadership
in the town square is a statue dedicated
to ig-11
who was instrumental to liberating this
town from mob gideon's imperial unit and
last season's finale meanwhile
no love apparently for kaweel probably
lying in a ditch somewhere that's what
happens when you fumble on the one yard
line the pub that they
used to meet and now has been converted
to a school one of the few non-culty
schools we've seen in the star wars
universe
and yes this girl does have the same
kind of hair braids that we've seen
rey have but this girl is not rey
herself
this is 9 aby ray would have been born
like six years after this
the teacher is a protocol droid who can
name one of the five
major trade routes in the galaxy anyone
how about the corellian run the heidian
way yes
the heidian way and uh just because i
was that student uh five major
hyperspace trade routes are the
corellian run that's the one connected
to han solo's home world of corellia the
corellian trait spine
the heidian way the perleven trade route
and the rima trade route these
trade routes are everything to the
civilization and control over them was
the basis of the naboo conflict in the
phantom menace the teacher continues to
talk about
reflecting how the capital of the
republic rotated from coruscant
to chandrila as described in chuck
wendig's aftermath series
also mentioned is maelstrom
the male's
yeah we saw that maelstrom when han solo
and the others did the kessel run in
that movie
on the map screen the oramesh translates
to gravitational vector and then
later solar limit and then orbital
something
and then key point and the teacher
mentions these sections of the galaxy
the mid rim
the expansion region the inner rim the
outer rim the core
the colonies and the deep core this is
important to what that
x-wing pilot later worries about with
threats rising in the outer rim
but these core worlds not taking it
seriously explaining why they were so
blindsided when the first order
fried all of them in the force awakens
baby yoda uses the force to swipe the
kids blue cookies or i think those are
macaroons
which that kid was just eating openly at
his desk doesn't even try to hide in his
backpack
ratio sans mithral character returns
from the pilot episode
there's no registration on the ship but
i'm pretty sure it belongs
i believe you two have met
his nervous mist is because he was just
calling in the razor crest
that is what brought the new republic
pilot there when they were reaching the
transponder log later and the mithral
says
i do not want to spend any more time in
carbonite still can't see out of my left
eye yeah that blindness is a callback to
when han solo was thought out of
carbonite and return of the jedi and
suffered temporary blindness
i can't see they take the speeder to the
supposedly
abandoned or skeletal crew imperial base
but the mithral wants to bounce
well i leave you out here in the lava
flats to walk home with whatever's left
in your humidity fest yeah a humidity
vest sounds like it could be based on
the still suits of dune
one of many ways dune has influenced the
world of star wars it still suits
recycled moisture to help beings in arid
climates and they find the
trexler marauder troop transport similar
to the one we saw bringing in the troops
in chapter 8 but with a few upgrades and
grief steals an imperial code cylinder
we actually saw
those in the pockets of grand moff
tarkin all the way back in the first
film
and they head over to the reactor column
to deactivate the cooling system so that
the heat from the lava will overpower
the station the same way that we saw
obi-wan trying to creep out on the
column to lower the death star shields
there's no guard rail on this come on a
great meta joke about how
none of these platforms have guard rails
osha would have a field day and then we
get to the stuff that gets the nerds
really exciting so they come across
two imperial scientists both are dressed
in similar uniforms with similar patches
as worn by dr pershing
insignia that looks a lot like the ones
worn by clones of kamino now it's not
exactly
similar but it's close enough and they
are desperately purging their
drive so you know we're gonna want to
see what was there and you can briefly
see it right before he shoots the panel
the display
looks quite similar to the display on
the tech that dr pershing was using to
examine the child in chapter three
and then they look over to see the
madness what uh
i thought you said this was a forward
operating base
i thought it was no this isn't a
military operation
this is a lab yes it is the official
audio description of this episode calls
these
hairless disfigured humanoids and one of
them
very closely resembles snoke same
bulbous scarred head same cheekbones
same lowered ear
the opening scene of the rise of
skywalker retconned snoke as a
genetically engineered potential host
body for palpatine's disembodied spirit
with cloned snokes visible in tanks on
exigal i
made smoke in the music plane here
is the deep bass vocals composed by john
williams for snoke in the sequel films
interestingly the concept art that
rolled under the credits of the end of
the episode another one of those
humanoids looks a bit like a zabrak
so maybe a mall clone was also being
considered we'll see
now mithral pulls up a recording of dr
pershing who clarifies how the child is
connected to this secret plot there were
promising effects for an entire
fortnight but then
sadly the body rejected the blood i
highly doubt we'll find a donor with a
higher m council i recommend that we
suspend all experimentation i fear that
the volunteer will meet the same
regrettable fate
if we proceed so the m count yeah refers
to macaroon count that [ __ ] is
off the charts and baby oda no i'm
kidding now it's obviously midichlorian
count
and i'm guessing they abbreviated to m
to avoid triggering fans with like
knee-jerk associations with the idea of
the force being
microbial bacteria but this confirms
many
things one moth gideon wants the child
for that kid's midichlorian rich for
sensitive
blood hoping to transfuse that blood
into genetically engineered host bodies
presumably this is part of the process
that eventually led to palpatine
resurrecting in a clone body a process
that the resistance speculated about in
that movie
dark science cloning
secret sony that's it so snoke it sounds
like was one
step in that process but palpatine 2.0
was the final form
this cloning process by way of
transplanting a consciousness has been
attempted in various star wars legends
stories but it almost always fails just
like dr pershing's describing it's
actually similar to the process by which
sifo diaz
the jedi who set up the secret kamino
cloning operation had his
genetic material his blood harvested and
pumped into grievous
though i don't think the force
sensitivity transfer worked grievous has
been established as not force sensitive
he's just a skilled lightsaber duelist
whether or not mothgating is aware of
the palpatine or
snoke connection or if he's just a
stubborn imperial loyalist
meant as a stepping stone to the first
order remains to be seen but
i think it is clear that he himself is
not force sensitive otherwise he would
just use his own blood for this
and it is clear now that baby yoda
himself was not a clone
but was probably born naturally and has
just since fallen into cloner's hands
and then finally that volunteer that
pershing mentioned pershing is halting
the experiment because he doesn't want
the volunteer to die
that would probably mean that volunteer
is a vip
rather than just like an expendable
nobody who's trying to pay for his
college tuition i'm thinking that vip
is palpatine's son shown in the
flashback in the rise of skywalker
that man himself was not a clone he
didn't look like a young
ian mcdermott he was a naturally born
son we actually went into that in one of
our classic big question episodes
palpatine
he [ __ ] but that guy never carried
palpatine's consciousness
and he hid his daughter rey so that she
would never be found for any kind of
similar plan
look i wasn't really crazy about the rey
palpatine plot in the rise of skywalker
but if anyone can give that cluster
a richer context and a deeper meaning
that fans appreciate
it is dave filoni the guy who made
attack of the clones worth re-watching
thanks to
all of his great work in the clone wars
so let's see where this goes gracious
sans is pretty hilarious to watch during
the escape he jumps in with his gun
pointed
after the shooting is stopped and then
he kind of like whack-a-moles up three
times
pointlessly before taking a shot the
transport chase is also
super fun to watch i love how the scout
troopers give chase on the speeder bikes
and two of them don't even survive that
initial descent and then the others have
to skid
their boot along the lava canyon floor
just to make that turn
just more great attention to detail that
gives this chase a tangible feel and
kara slams one against the canyon wall
pretty dark for her to celebrate but
remember this woman did lose
everyone when these imps blew up
alderhon and when the base explodes
behind them from that geyserine lava you
can see a shockwave
blast out that rattles them on the
transport signaling to them that their
mission is
accomplished but hey not so fast tie
fighters are now closing in
i love how karen notices them just by
the sound of their signature screen
i may have been premature similarly i
love how much time we spend in the
cockpits with the imperial pilots the
set people are billowing in
dust particles showing how these pilots
must have rushed into these cockpits
while lava and ash was exploding around
them
just makes this dogfight feel so much
more personal the razer crest swoops in
to save him cookie snack and baby yoda
throws his hands up as a razor crest
climbs like on a roller coaster and yeah
his stomach reacts afterwards the same
way
new republic x-wing pilot captain carson
tava returns from chapter 10.
there's something going on out here they
don't believe it on the core worlds but
it's true
these aren't isolated incidents they
need to be stopped before it's too late
yeah this is the possible clue pointing
to the rise of the first order
something that spawned in unknown
regions and caught those core worlds
completely by surprise and then after
learning how she lost everyone on
alderaan but failing to recruit her for
now
tivon leaves her with this badge with
the insignia of the rebellion
and then we see moff gideon's new
massive ship it wedges down into frame
matching the visual of the imperial star
destroyer in the opening shot of the
first star wars film echoing for us that
awe of imperial might at the height of
the empire's power
now that membinese engineer confirms a
tracking device has been planted on the
razer crest
telling us that moth gideon will be able
to follow mando to corvus and hopefully
that will mean a lightsaber duel between
gideon and the darksaber and ahsokatano
with her whitebladed sabers that she got
from the inquisitors and that
communication officer responds
you will be well rewarded in the new era
yeah that new era
could refer to the first order which
could mean moff gideon is more hands on
in this transition
or still this group could just be part
of an offshoot imperial group with like
related empire 2.0 plans that could get
violently overtaken by the people who
found the first order and the word
passes along to gideon
and we will be ready so what are these
troopers the black armor first looked
like to me like the death troopers seen
in rogue one some are suggesting shadow
troopers from the games they wield the
lightsabers but i don't think so notice
the nearby scientist jumpsuit it bears
the crest of the
imperial department of military research
it's from an older star wars rpg this
connects us to the
dark troopers so dark troopers
specifically these are phase three dark
troopers
super advanced battle droids from the
dark forces game originally
and this was further confirmed by the
official audio description of the
episode which states quote
he turns toward a shadowy cubicle where
light gleams off
shiny black armor resembling his own
rows of similar compartments sprawl
through the bay with an
engineer tending to immobilized dark
troopers
contained within now i'm sure that audio
description could be like generic
lowercase dark
troopers but all the other clues point
in this direction so no i don't think
these troopers are like waiting for baby
oda blood to activate
but they are likely to be terrifying
droids that is going to trigger
mando's painful memories of losing his
parents to the separatist super battle
droids during the clone wars
and next episode we're going to be
headed to corvus to meet a socatano an
episode that i expect to be one of the
biggest of the series
season two just keeps bringing it i am
so excited to keep making these kinds of
in-depth cinematic analyses of star wars
it's really more than just a pile of
easter eggs and references for me it's
true
art it's worth analyzing the craft and
if you like that approach
please subscribe to new rockstars hit
that notification bell follow me on
instagram eavos follow new rockstars
we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you